Hank: Good morning John!
I am still excited about Pizzamas; this is
all very exciting except for your mustache,
which is not exciting at all.
But you know who I'm not as excited as?
This guy:
Train Guy: Oh my god!
WAAAAA!
Hank: I consider myself to be something of
an expert in the genre’s of viral videos.
There's, there's lots of them: there's epic
cutes, and epic wins, epic fails, epic weirds.
But for me, as a viewer, the most pure and
rewarding kind of viral video is the epic
excitement.
Beautiful, unabashed, uncontrolled excitement.
It's such a wonderful feeling that just watching
other people have it makes me feel wonderful.
And John, today, I want to be stupid excited
about the very idea of excitement.
Meta!
We're gonna start out with Rachael Nedrow,
whose voice you may have heard in a couple
of Skrillex songs.
Among many other things in what I'm sure is
a full and complete life, Rachael has competitively
stacked cups.
I'm not sure how difficult this is, I'm not
sure amazing it is, it certainly looks amazing
and impressive.
But her reaction is the thing I'm here for:
Rachael: Yes!
Oh my gosh!
Hank: Auhhh!
Now let's look at the video we started this
video with, this guy loves trains:
Train Guy: I've been waiting for this moment
for months and it's finally here.
Look at that, a 1953 EA.
Woohoo!
(train horn) Oh my god!
(screaming) Listen to that horn!
That horn!
Next, we have Aleksander Gamme, who is hiking
across the Antarctic.
When you're doing this, so you don't have
to carry your supplies the whole way, you
leave some of your supplies in caches along
the way, so you can pick them up on the way
back.
And in his final cache, after surviving on
what I assume is not the tastiest food in
the world, he discovers that he has left some
treats.
Aleksander: Yah!
Yaah!
Yaaah!
Hank: I mean, he put those cheese doodles
there didn't, he know what to expect?
I guess he forgot and it was just the most
surprising bag of cheese doodles of all time!
And surprise seems to be a part of it, not
knowing what the outcome is and then finding
indeed that there is more.
For example, there was another historic engine
on the back of that other engine and the guy
got even more excited:
Train Guy: Oh no!
It's a BL2 too!
Ah!
The SNC 52!
Hank: Sometimes it's amazing to see people
get excited about things that you just don't
understand why they're so excited but yes,
yes, I feel it too!
Other times you're right there with that person,
like I'm willing to bet there are a lot of
people who wish they might be able to like
grow up and become Luke Skywalker, but actually
becoming a hero in the Star Wars saga not
something that happens to very many people.
But thanks to some foresight, and the internet,
we get to be there with John Boyega as he
sees the Star Wars teaser trailer and the
part that he plays in it:
John: "Woah oh oh!
Oh oh oh!
What?!
What?!"
Hank: Yess!
Finally, this list would not be complete without
the most famous internet excited guy of all
time, Yosemitebear, as he comes across a double
rainbow that had become, through the magic
of the internet and the work of the Gregory
brothers, legendary.
Yosemitebear: Double rainbow all the way across
the sky!
It's so intense.
Hank: Sometimes it feels like the only moment
when it's culturally acceptable to feel that
kind of uncontrolled excitement is in sporting
events.
And I'm not really into sports.
For me, the last time I felt like that level
of excitement and just couldn't control myself
was in 2012 when the Curiosity Rover definitely
was safe on the surface of Mars.
What I realized though, watching these clips,
it that there is so much to be excited about.
These people are open to the beauty and amazingness
of nature and of human accomplishment, and
of their own accomplishments.
And they're kind of my heroes.
I wanna be more like them.
It's kind of funny, but I feel like it requires
work, to say to myself 'Don't shut it down,
Love things, by yourself or with others and
without fear.'
These videos for me are a master class in
being open to the wondrousness of nature and
of the human condition and of the self.
So I put them in a playlist in the description
below, you can click on it and watch all of
them, and it's just wonderful thing to do.
John, I'll see you tomorrow.
I'm freaking my dog out.
"Why are you screaming, dad?"
I need to make a video, and I'm going to scream,
during it, so just lay down and just assume
that I'm doing human things that are weird.